♪
>> IT SHOULD OUTRAGE EVERY
SINGLE PERSON.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU’RE A
DEMOCRAT, I DON’T CARE IF YOU’RE
A ARE MONEY.
THE ONLY THEY CAN THAT JOE
BIDEN -- THING THAT JOE BIDEN IS
DOING ON THE BORDER, HE’S TRYING
TO ACCELERATE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEY’RE BUILDING MORE FACILITIES
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
EXPEDITING THE RELEASE OF
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS INTO THE
INTERIOR.
HE IS THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN OUR
LIFETIMES, INDEED IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY, WHO HAS EVER
ATTEMPTED SUCH A PROGRAM.
MARIA: AND THAT WAS FORMER
SENIOR WHITE HOUSE ADVISER
STEVEN MILLER ON THIS PROGRAM
EARLIER THIS MONTH REVEALING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S PLAN TO
PUSH PEOPLE THROUGH THE
FACILITIES QUICKLY, ALLEVIATE
OVERCROWDING AT THE BORDER AND
HOUSE THEM IN NEW FACILITIES.
NOW HE WANTS TO PAY FOR IT.
IF THEY’RE DOING IT, LAST MONTH
BORDER PATROL REPORTED OVER
178,000 APPREHENSIONS.
THAT’S A 20-YEAR HIGH.
YET AS OF LAST WEEK, ONLY 455
MINORS WERE IN THEIR CUSTODY.
WHERE ARE THESE PEOPLE GOING?
CHAD WOLF IS CURRENTLY A
VISITING FELLOW AT THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION CAN.
SECRETARY, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE PUSHING THE
MIGRANTS INTO THE INTERIOR OF
OUR COUNTRY AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BUILT A
LOT MORE HOUSING TO HOUSE THESE
PEOPLE, BUT THEY’RE ALSO TRYING
TO HELP THEM CONNECT WITH
SO-CALLED SPONSORS OR FAMILY
THAT THEY STAY THEY HAVE IN
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOUR REACTION TO WHERE WE ARE
HALFWAY THROUGH THE YEAR NOW.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON, MARIA.
I THINK WHAT WE CURRENTLY ARE
AND WHAT WE SEE GOING ON AT THE
BORDER IS WE CONTINUE TO BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A HISTORIC CRISIS
ON OUR SOUTHWEST BORDER.
YOU TALKED ABOUT DHS AND THE
PROGRESS THEY’VE MADE.
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE TRYING TO
TAKE A VICTORY LAP AT THE MOMENT
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY’RE MOVING
MIGRANTS, MAINLY MINORS, FROM
ONE GOVERNMENT FACILITY TO9
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT FACILITY AND
SAYING WE’VE SOLVED THE PROBLEM
AND THE CRISIS.
AND THAT’S ANYTHING, THEY HAVE
DONE ANYTHING BUT THAT.
SOLVING THE CRISIS IS ACTUALLY
TRYING TO STOP THE ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR.
THEY’RE NOT INTERESTED IN DOING
THAT.
THEY’VE TORN DOWN A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
BACK IN 2019 AND 2020, AND THEY
HAVE NOT REPLACED IT WITH ANY
PROGRAMS OR POLICIES TO ADDRESS
THE ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR.
AGAIN, THEY’RE JUST SIMPLY
FACILITATING MORE AND MORE OF
THESE MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
MARIA: OKAY.
WHAT IS, WHAT IS NEEDED AT THIS
POINT?
I MEAN, LOOK, THIS IS A
DANGEROUS TREK.
THIS IS NOT JUST AN ECONOMIC
ISSUE FOR THIS COUNTRY, BUT THIS
IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WHERE
YOUNG GIRLS ARE GETTING SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AS THEY A MAKE THIS
TREK.
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT’S NEEDED IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU’RE NOT ONLY PUTTING THE
RIGHT POLICIES IN PLACE, BUT
YOU’RE PUTTING THE RIGHT
MESSAGING IN PLACE.
AND SO THEY NEED TO BRING BACK
EITHER THE E MIGRANT PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS, THEY NEED TO SHOW
THAT IT’S NOT OKAY TO CONTINUE
TO SMUGGLE MINORS AND FAMILIES
ACROSS THAT BORDER.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT’S TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE’S A
CONSEQUENCE TO THAT BEHAVIOR.
SO AS LONG AS THOSE POPULATIONS
STAY IN THE U.S. ONCE THEY COME
ACROSS THAT BORDER, THESE
NUMBERS AND THIS FLOW IS GOING
TO CONTINUE.
IT’S NOT UNTIL THESE FOLKS ARE
REMOVED PROPERLY BACK TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES, BACK TO MEXICO
AND ELSEWHERE THAT YOU’RE GOING
TO START TO SEE SOME OF THIS
DECREASE.
IT’S WHAT WE DID IN 2019 AND
2020, AND IT WORKED.
THE NUMBERS WENT DOWN, THE
APPREHENSIONS WENT DOWN, AND WE
GOT THE BORDER UNDER CONTROL.
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS.
THERE IS A PLAYBOOK.
THIS ADMINISTRATION SIMPLY
CHOOSES NOT TO INSTITUTE SOME OF
THOSE POLICIES.
MARIA: YEAH.
WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
BUDGET THIS MORNING WHICH
PRESIDENT BIDEN UNVEILED ON
FRIDAY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY MAYORKAS TOLD
LAWMAKERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING $52.2
BILLION IN FUNDING FOR THE
COMING FISCAL YEAR, LEAVING THE
AGENCY’S BUDGET UNCHANGED.
SO DESPITE THIS MASSIVE SURGE,
THE BUDGET IS UNCHANGED, BUT NOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY TO PAY FOR ALL OF
THIS HOUSING.
I MEAN, IT JUST GETS ME THAT
THERE’S ABSOLUTELY NO EFFORT
WHATSOEVER TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
COMING HERE ILLEGAL, JUMPING THE
LINE IN FRONT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO IT
LEGALLY, GET THEIR GREEN CARD.
AND INSTEAD HE’SING ASKING FOR
MONEY -- HE’S ASKING FOR MONEY
THROUGH CONGRESS TO PAY FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND THESE ADDITIONAL
HOUSING FACILITIES THAT THEY
JUST BUILT.
>> WELL, IT’S UNFATHOMABLE THAT
DHS AND ALL THE HOMELAND
SECURITY THREATS THAT THE G.
DEPARTMENT TRIES TO ASSESS AND
ADDRESS ON A DAILY BASIS THAT
THERE’S NOT INCREASED FUNDING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
OF IT’S NOT ONLY THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER AND THE MIGRANT, THE
HUMANITARIAN AND SECURITY
CRISIS, IT’S ALSO CYBERSECURITY
AND A VARIETY OF THESE THREATS,
THREATS FROM CHINA THAT WE’RE
DEALING WITH THAT THE DEPARTMENT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
FORWARD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT AMERICANS ARE
SAFE AND SECURE, AND IT’S GOING
TO TAKE RESOURCES TO DO THAT.
THE FACT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS NOT FOCUSING ON THAT AND IS
FOCUSING ON BUILDING THESE
FACILITIES AND GIVING MORE MONEY
TO HHS TO BUILD MORE OF THESE
FACILITIES, AGAIN, SHOWS ME THAT
THEY’RE NOT SERIOUS ABOUT TRYING
TO STOP THE PROBLEM.
INSTEAD OF MANAGING THE CRISIS,
THEY NEED TO SOLVE THE CRISIS
AND, AGAIN, THEY’RE NOT
CURRENTLY DOING THAT.
WE HEARD THE SECRETARY JUST
YESTERDAY TALK ABOUT POSSIBLY
REPROGRAMMING MONEY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
HUMANITARIAN AND SECURITY CRISIS
ON THE SOUTHWEST BORDER.
CLEARLY, THERE’S A RESOURCE NEED
THERE.
CLEARLY, THEY’RE SPENDING MORE
MONEY THAN THEY HAVE AT THE
MOMENT.
SO AS WE LOOK TOWARDS THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR, THAT’S GOING TO
CONTINUE OUT OF THESE NUMBERS
AND THE SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR
THESE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE.
MARIA: YEAH.
AND ALSO WE’RE ALL WONDERING
WHERE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
GOING.
WE SPOKE WITH SENATOR MARSHA
BLACKBURN RECENT9LY, SHE JOINED
ME ON FOX BUSINESS ON MY MORNING
PROGRAM THERE TO TALK TALK TO US
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SEEN
OR SHE HAS SEEN PLANES TOUCHING
DOWN IN CHATTANOOGA FILLED WITH
MIGRANTS.
THEY SENT THEM TO TENNESSEE.
KEN PAXTON IN TEXAS IS ALSO
QUESTIONING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY’RE ACTUALLY SENDING MY
GRANTS TO ED STATES -- MIGRANTS
TO RED STATES BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE COST WILL FALL TO
THE STATE.
HERE’S MARSHA BLACKBURN JOINING
ME RECENTLY ON THIS VERY ISSUE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ABSOLUTELY LIVING IN FANTASY
LAND IF THEY’RE TELLING PEOPLE
THAT BORDER IS SECURE.
THEY HAVE APPREHENDED 500,000
ILLEGAL ENTRANTS SINCE JOE BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE.
AND WHAT THEY’VE BEGUN TO DO IS
TO MOVE THEM OUT AND ABOUT
AROUND THE COUNTRY SO THAT THEY
ARE OFFLOADING THE COSTS FOR
HOUSING CHILD SERVICES, HEALTH
CARE, EDUCATION TO THE STATES
AND THE COUNTIES.
AND AND WHAT WE FOUND OUT IS
THAT THEY HAD THESE PLANES
COMING IN TO CHATTANOOGA,
PUTTING THESE CHILDREN ON BUSES
AND THEN TAKING THEM TO
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE AREA.
MARIA: THAT’S ACTUALLY
EXTRAORDINARY, SECRETARY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
AND, BY THE WAY, ANDY BIGGS, THE
ARIZONA CONGRESSMAN, IS CALLING
ON AL HAND DEGREE MAYORKAS --
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS TO BE REMOVED
IN ALL OF THIS.
HE WRITES A NEW OP-ED FOR
FOXNEWS.COM, AND IN IT HE WRITES
THE RATIONALE FOR THE BORDER
CRISIS CAN BE SET AT THE FEET OF
BIDEN’S HAND-PICKED HOMELAND
SECURITY.
MAYORKAS PREVARICATIONS ARE AN
UTTER FAILURE AND DEMONSTRATE
THAT HE IS UNFIT TO SERVE.
IF MAYORKAS REFUSES TO STEP
DOWN, CONGRESS SHOULD INITIATE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL, A COUPLE OF COMMENTS.
SENATOR MARSHA BLACKBURN IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AT THE
BORDER RIGHT NOW IS THEY ARE
BREAKING THE SYSTEM.
THERE ARE TOO MANY MINORS IN
CUSTODY FOR THE AMOUNT OF
FACILITIES THAT THEY HAVE, SO
WHAT DO THEY HAVE TO DO?
THEY THEN HAVE TO MOVE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY.
SO WHAT WE SEE NOW IS THAT EVERY
CITY, EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
IS NOW A BORDER STATE AND
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY ARE
PUSHING THESE POPULATIONS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BROKEN THE SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM HAS NEVER BEEN
DESIGNED OR ACCOUNTED FOR TO
HOLD THESE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
AND TO PROCESS THESE NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
THESE ARE HISTORIC HIGHS,
21-YEAR HIGHS IN THE AMOUNT OF
FOLKS THAT ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER AND INTO FACILITIES.
SHE’S EXACTLY RIGHT, THEY ARE
MOVING THESE MINORS, THESE
FAMILY UNITS AND OTHERS TO ALL
SORTS OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IS SO SHE’S 100% CORRECT ON
THAT.
LOOK, I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE DHS SECRETARY
AND THE TYPES OF POLICIES THAT
HE IS PURSUING.
I THINK THEY’RE MAKING THE
COUNTRY LESS SAFE, THEY’RE
MAKING OUR MEN AND WOMEN OF
BORDER PATROL, THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS LESS SAFE,
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THEY’RE DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THE MIGRANTS WHEN THEY ENCOURAGE
THE MIGRANTS TO A MAKE THIS
DANGEROUS TREK UP.
AND DANGEROUS HE CONTINUES TO
SAY THE BORDER IS CLOSE AND
SECURE.
THAT’S A LIE.
HE’S MISLEADING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON PURPOSE BECAUSE HE’S
DONE IT, HE’S DONE IT MULTIPLE,
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR
THAT, AND YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHY
HE IS DOING THAT, AND I THINK HE
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT.
BUT AT THE END E OF THE FEW DAY,
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING THE
HOMELAND AND MAKING SURE WE HAVE
THE RIGHT POLICIES IN PLACE.
MARIA: GREAT TO SEE YOU, CHAD
WOLF.
WE, OF COURSE, WILL CONTINUE TO
SPOTLIGHT IT.